correspondance que vous êtes en train de
dire que vous avez voulu en faisant
quelque chose vraiment de treize objets
qu tout faire prendre conscience de ce
qui se passait à l'époque et que ça a
été mal pris c'est à dire que les gens
ont mal compris le message et que les
invités maladroit c'est exactement vous
vous avez vous été maladroit j'ai une
valeur actuelle alors je vous dis
geoffroy vigneron valeurs actuelles
voilà dans la tête des gens c'est très
très à droite vous êtes très très à
droite
moi je suis je suis je suis de droite je
suis conservateur je suis réac si vous
voulez peu importe mais par contre je
suis pas extrémiste école proche de
laurence tailler coup de deux morts j'ai
beaucoup de mal moi à me situer par
rapport aux personnalités politiques
d'aujourd'hui enfin lors on se connaît
bien
mais comment vous dire je ne sais pas je
me situe dans un courant de pensée qui
existe en france depuis très longtemps
que le mouvement conservateur qui
n'existent pas que pas vraiment
représenté en réalité dans l'échiquier
politique aujourd'hui donc je me sens un
peu orphelin politique par contre j'ai
des idées que j'exprime régulièrement en
tout cas jusqu'à présent je les écrivais
régulièrement sur les plateaux de
télévision elles sont transparentes
on a un journal dans lequel on écrit
toutes les semaines on a un site sur
lequel on publie 30 articles par jour je
veux dire que la question que tout le
monde se pose je crois que je vais la
pause et thermos est-ce que valeurs
actuelles c'est un journal à tendance
raciste pas du tout mais pas du tout est
ce que je peux juste je vois pas ce que
ça du tout question
je vais évidemment de le dire mais ya la
loi pons et si ballack cela dit je suis
valeur mais je suis condamné pour
racisme comme ça a été le cas de valeurs
actuelles vous avez été condamné en 2015
pour provocation à la haine à la pro à
la discrimination à la violence contre
des populations roms
voilà ses valeurs actuelles qui a été
condamné l'homme visait pas que les
personnes noires enfin je sais pas si
c'est mon tour dans les allées du
ranquet bien j'ai lu le texte et j'ai
regardé l'image le texte je le trouve
abject que vous ne compreniez pas que
danièle obono et peut être vexé
alors que vous l'avez fait con comme il
aurait très bien pu dire non mais calais
peut être blessé pardon parce que vous
la décrivez dans le texte comme une
personne inintelligente nous en prenez à
son physique donc il ya du sexisme vous
la décrivez sur un marché d'esclaves
blessés dans un même son amour propre
parce qu'elle n'a pas été acheté je vous
expliquais parce que nous parce que elle
a 40 ans le fait qu'elle ait 40 ans elle
et lui
lui a permis d'échapper aux viols vous
dépeignez une afrique horrible
misérables où les gens se baladent pieds
nus ou quand danièle obono va libérer
son africanité
en fait je suis désolé pour à danièle
obono si elle ne regarde qu'elle doit
subir à nouveau ce texte mais vous
expliquez que elle va des flics et au
milieu des cafards donc ça c'est du
racisme je suis désolé mais personne n'a
jamais nié le fait que l'esclavagé
pratiqué sur le sol africain
si vous n'avez pas besoin de personne
n'a pas nié je vous mets au défi de
mettre un moment où danielle bonneau a
nié le fait que et en plus là c'est le
seul moment où l'occident intervient
dans votre texte c'est pour certains
missionnaires français qui libère
danièle obono des terribles aux
africains au xviiie siècle alors son
esclavage se perpétue est-ce que c'est
dans les colonies parce que vous savez
bien la réalité c'est qu'ils avaient
très mal j'ai côtoyé le bonheur est lui
aussi terminé dans une colonie française
jouera je trouve l'ex extrêmement
violent je le trouve raciste je le
trouve sexiste je le trouve vraiment
très très difficile à dire des divisions
faut que j'arrive à eric aussi parce que
j'ai pas réfléchi regret puisque ça
vient d'arriver
le tu dis le texte est abject d'accord
mais mais en réalité je dis juste avant
exactement la même chose ça décrit une
réalité abjecte et pas d'accord comme
dit qu'elle est blessée dans son
amour-propre parce qu'elle n'ait pas
acheté en tant qu'esclave mais quoi vous
du cac 40 ans elle était trop vieille
pour être vieux violée pourquoi vous
vous moquez de pacific dont 60 de son
visage de cette silhouette qui n'est pas
longiligne qu'est-ce que ça à voir
on s'est moqué du man is et en
l'appelant par son nom le principe de
ces fictions c'est aussi de malmener un
peu les personnages qu'on se fillon je
pense pas qu'il était ravi de se
retrouver au pied de la guillotine
eric zemmour a dit hier sur ses new
skies l'avait trouvé qu'on souhaitait de
sa gueule dans ce nom steak c'est moi
qui les ai écrits et qu'on le malmener
un peu et rokhaya diallo par le droit de
trouver exactement la même chose
encore une fois à partir du moment où on
a compris que c'était un sujet pour elle
on lui a dit qu est-il personnel on ne
voulait pas la blesser qu'ont voulu
présenter des excuses
je veux dire d'accord mais maintenant je
dis très précisément que si le texte est
abjecte c'est parce que la réalité de
l'époque étaient injectés contrairement
à ce que vous dites
elle est niée aujourd'hui moyens j'ai
débattu pendant l'après midi avec les
charmants militants de la ldn à la ligue
de défense nord africaine qui m'ont
expliqué que non au piano bruno lasnier
dire que vous en prenez à elle averti
elle est une des porte parole médiatique
sur du mouvement des génisses donc du
coup sur le fond c'est quoi loupé un
sujet sur le plus de poids voilà ça
c'est la première chose
ensuite pour répondre les deux
objections une vingtaine de questions
sont des questions qui portent sur
l'intention je ne peux pas faire mieux
que ce que je fais depuis trois jours
que de te dire l'intention qui était la
mienne dit je crois pas à ta sincérité
qu'est-ce que je peux faire de plus je
ne vois pas je dis je ne voulais pas la
blesser je dis que l'intention était de
démontrer sa tournée rater notre coup
c'est une certitude
à partir du moment où personne ne l'a
compris je suis d'accord pour dire que
c'est raté
c'est raté ses voiles à terme sidère
c'est que tu puisse dire je ne comprends
pas que le dessin d'une femme noire
enchaîné qui paraît dans valeurs
actuelles 80 une ligne éditoriale très
particulière une ligne d'extrême droite
soit mal en effet prises soient tus et
cynique
soit tu es inconscient ce qui arrive et
tes écrits d'avancé jeudi par le monde
et choqué quand il ya 99 je suis prêt
vous a coupé au front
on s'est loupé mlg même dire si je
devais aussi je pouvais rembobinez en
sachant tout ce qui s'est passé je ferai
évidemment extrêmement différemment
parce que je ne voulais pas choquer et
je ne voulais pas provoquer de polémique